A variety of machine learning algorithms
can be used for intrusion detection.
These include Bayesian networks.
Bayesian networks encode the conditional
probabilities among observed events.
For example,
how likely an email is sent by a user
if the current time is 2:00 AM.
If a low probability activity
takes place it is an anomaly.
Markov models, a Markov model
is a set of states that are connected
by transitional probabilities.
For example, Markov models can be used
to model legitimate website names
because, the traditional probabilities
from one letter to the next
should be similar to that of
real dictionary words because,
users need to type the website names.
On the other hand, a randomly spelled
website name is anomalous and
may be used by botnets for C and C, or
command control, because bots don't
have to type the website names.
Neural networks.
A neural network simulates how human
brain perform reasoning and learning.
They are one of the most powerful
machine learning approaches.
Clustering and outlier detection.
Clustering groups the observed data into
clusters based on some similarity or
distance measure.
And then identify subsequently observed
data as either belonging to a cluster or
as an outlier.
For example,
traffic from the internal network
to the company's internal web
server have common characteristics
that can be grouped into clusters
based on the webpages visited.
On the other hand, an attack may
access data on the web server
that's rarely visited,
which makes it an outlier.